[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute geht es weiter mit der Plätzchenbäckerei.
Ich zeige euch heute, wie man aus einem Teig
ganz viele verschiedene Plätzchen zubereiten kann,
also wirklich eine richtig große Plätzchenvielfalt.
Dieser Teig nennt sich Mürbeteig
und es ist ein 1-2-3-Mürbeteig.
Denn ein Teil ist Zucker,
zwei Teile sind Butter
und drei Teile sind Mehl.
Könnt ihr euch wirklich super merken
und je nachdem, wie viel ihr backen wollt,
macht ihr eben so viel an Menge.
Also ich habe jetzt hier tatsächlich
einen Teig schon vorbereitet
und habe diese Menge genommen.
Das sind nämlich
300 Gramm Zucker,
600 Gramm kalte Butter
und 900 Gramm Mehl.
Ihr könnt Dinkel oder Weizen nehmen.
Und als Zusatz nehme ich dann noch Vanilleextrakt
und eine Prise Salz.
Also das sind so die Basiszutaten.
Salz ist immer ganz wichtig.
Denn, auch wenn es wirklich nur ein viertel Teelöffel ist
bei der großen Menge jetzt,
ist es wirklich so, dass Salz einfach noch mal
dieses i-Tüpfelchen an Geschmack bringt,
also wirklich so den Geschmack noch mal pusht.
Vanilleextrakt nehme ich beim Basisteig.
Aber, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Zimtkekse
draus machen will oder Kaffee,
je nachdem, was es halt wird
und wenn der andere Geschmack
das Vanilleextrakt übertönen würde,
dann spare ich natürlich Vanilleextrakt,
also da mache ich es nicht rein,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Und jetzt ist eigentlich nur ganz wichtig,
dass die Butter ganz kalt ist
oder dass der Teig eben auch gleich lange gekühlt wird.
Ihr könnt jetzt hier Zucker oder Puderzucker nehmen.
Puderzucker ist halt eher so eine Kostenfrage,
also das ist ein bisschen teurer.
Ihr könnt auch den Zucker im Hochleistungsmixer
einfach selber vermahlen und dann habt ihr Puderzucker.
Aber ich finde es einfach ganz gut,
den Teig jetzt schnell zusammenzukneten,
entweder mit den Händen
oder mit einem Messer geht das auch
– deswegen hieß der Mürbeteig früher auch Hackteig –
oder eben einfach in der Küchenmaschine
mit so einem Flachrührer
oder auch mit einem Knethaken von einem Handrührgerät.
Also ihr habt wirklich allerlei Optionen.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier die Zutaten einfach alle rein.
Und wirklich nur ganz kurz verrühren,
bis alles vermengt ist und der Teig noch schön kalt bleibt.
[Musik]
Also da gibt es wirklich groß nichts zu beachten.
Und das ist auch so ein Teig,
den könnt ihr wirklich supereinfach veganisieren,
indem ihr einfach vegane Butter nehmt.
Murat würde jetzt sagen:
"Aus Schleswig-Holstein."
Ja. Und was ich beim Plätzchenbacken immer beachte,
weil ich ja wirklich, wenn ich mal backe,
dann auch recht viel backe:
Ich packe mir praktisch alle Zutaten,
alle Vorräte auf den Tisch,
habe dann alles griffbereit
und dann könnt ihr wirklich ganz, ganz schnell
alles zubereiten.
So.
Und jetzt verrühren.
[Musik]
Und hier könnt ihr den Teig jetzt entweder hell zubereiten,
so wie ich,
oder ihr könnt auch eine Schokovariante machen
und könnt einfach ein bisschen Mehl wegnehmen
und Kakao zufügen, also Backkakao ohne Zucker.
Ach, ich weiß, ich habe früher immer Kaka-o gesagt.
Bei uns sagt man
– Josh, wie sagst du das?
>> JOSH: Kaka-o.
>> SALLY: Kaka-o, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja. Aber ich habe mich umgewöhnt,
weil meine Zuschauer haben mich verändert.
Die haben mich immer ausgelacht,
wenn ich Kaka-o gesagt habe,
und haben immer gesagt: "Das heißt so nicht.
Das heißt so nicht."
Und dann kam Ela,
weißt, so voll das kleine Kind,
und redet einfach hochdeutscher als die Mutter.
Und die hat gesagt: "Mama, das heißt Kakao."
Ja.
Da habt ihr mich verändert.
Ich sage es euch, ich sage nicht mehr Kaka-o.
Ja.
Da ist sie weg die alte Sally,
die Waghäuselerin.
Und dann sagen die Menschen: "Ha, die hat sich verändert.
Die sagt nicht mal mehr Kaka-o."
Dann sage ich: "Ja. Das wart ihr."
Achje!
Jetzt habt ihr hier einen schönen geschmeidigen Teig.
Und das ist auch wirklich ein Teig,
der wunderbar ohne Ei auskommt.
Sehr, sehr schön.
Und jetzt ist wichtig, den zu kühlen.
Ich würde ihn jetzt nicht so als Rolle kühlen,
sondern einfach mal halbieren,
dass er möglichst schnelle auch kühlt
– schnelle?! –
möglichst schnell auch kühlt.
Schön flach drücken.
Und so kann ich den jetzt für ein bis zwei Stunden kühlen.
Ihr könnt ihn aber auch gerne schon am Tag vorher
zubereiten und vorbereiten.
Dann habt ihr nämlich am nächsten Tag
direkt fertigen Teig zum Plätzchenbacken.
Ich kühle den
und dann geht es direkt los mit Variante Nummer eins.
[Musik]
Ich habe mir den fertig gekühlten Teig jetzt einfach portioniert.
Denn ich mache ja heute wirklich alle Variationen daraus.
Und ich habe jetzt hier 300-Gramm-Bällchen.
Ich gebe es euch im Blog aber einfach so an
als 1-2-3 Rezept,
also mit 100 Gramm Zucker, 100 Gramm Butter
– 200 Gramm Butter und 300 Gramm Mehl
und schreibe euch da dann die richtige Menge rein.
Was ich jetzt zuerst mache:
Ich werde die erste Variation machen.
Das sind die Nougat-Plätzchen.
Und dafür werde ich jetzt hier erst mal Haselnüsse mahlen.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich jetzt meinen ersten Teig,
knete hier die Haselnüsse unter.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr die vorher
noch in einer Pfanne rösten, bis sie lecker duften.
Dann intensiviert sich nämlich das Haselnussaroma.
Und ihr könnt im Prinzip jetzt jeden Geschmack,
den ihr möchtet, reinbringen,
also auch Mandeln oder Walnüsse,
Kokosnüsse.
Und die anderen stelle ich solang wieder in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Hier gebe ich jetzt einfach für die Bindung
noch ein Eigelb dazu.
Denn durch die Haselnüsse ist das Ganze
natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen
auseinandergegangen.
Hier nehme ich jetzt das Eigelb für die Bindung.
Und das Eiweiß brauche ich gleich zum Bestreichen.
Also ihr seht auch schon,
diese Plätzchensorte entwickelt sich jetzt gerade.
Ich habe einfach an Josh gedacht.
Denn der Josh mag Nougat
und deswegen kriegt der Josh Nougat-Plätzchen.
Gut.
Jetzt habe ich eine gute Teigbindung.
Ich forme das Ganze zu einer Rolle,
die etwa einen Durchmesser von 4 cm hat.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr die Rolle dann habt,
dann muss sie noch mal gekühlt werden.
Ihr könnt sie einfach in Folie einpacken.
Ich nehme hier Bienenwachstücher.
Die könnt ihr nämlich wiederbenutzen.
Dann müsst ihr sie nicht wegschmeißen.
Und dann wird die Rolle so, wie sie ist, einfach eingefroren,
damit sie ihre schöne Form bekommt
und eben auch behält beim Schneiden gleich.
[Musik]
Die Keksrolle ist jetzt schön fest.
Die ist eingefroren.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier ein Eiweiß.
Das gebe ich hier mal rein.
Hier habe ich jetzt gehackte Nüsse.
Da-da-daa!
Mh.
Ich mache es auf der Matte.
Denn der Teller ist rund
und die Rolle ist lang.
Und Josh so:
"Hä? Was macht sie?
Was macht sie da?"
Und wie gesagt, Bienenwachstücher
kann man immer wiederverwenden.
Die werden einfach abgewaschen
und dann sind sie wieder einsatzbereit.
Jetzt wird praktisch die Rolle mit Eiweiß bestrichen.
Und dann könnt ihr hier
einmal komplett
mit den Nüssen.
Und das wäre jetzt im Teller schlecht geworden.
Das hätte nicht so gut geklappt.
[Musik]
Und dann nehmt ihr euch ein Schneidebrett,
ein Waffelbrett
von Sturmwaffel,
und schneidet jetzt im Prinzip die Kekse runter.
Also einfach ungefähr
0,5 mm dicke Scheiben.
Und die legt ihr dann auf euer Backblech.
Und das sind halt echt coole Kekse.
Denn dafür braucht man weder einen Ausrollstab
noch einen Ausstecher.
Die sind echt megacool!
Die kann jeder machen.
So. Wer hat von euch aufgepasst?
0,5 cm natürlich.
5 mm.
[Musik]
Und da muss ich jetzt sagen,
den Teig muss ich jetzt nicht mehr kühlen.
Denn es war ja eiskalt jetzt aus dem Gefrierschrank.
Also direkt in den Backofen.
Ich mache jetzt nur noch das zweite Blech fertig.
Denn bei Heißluft werden alle gleichzeitig gebacken.
Schön!
Man hat keinen Keksteigverlust.
Man muss nichts ausrollen.
Die sind echt superschnell gemacht.
Ich finde, die kann man sogar super vorbereiten,
als Rolle einfrieren.
Und auch unter dem Jahr – mein Gott!
Also man kann ja auch Kekse unter dem Jahr essen.
Man muss ja nicht bis Weihnachten warten.
Oder? Hat das jemand...
>> JOSH: Nee.
>> SALLY: Wer unterschreibt das?
Alle.
[Musik]
Die Plätzchen sind jetzt fertig gebacken und abgekühlt.
Einen habe ich probiert und ich muss sagen,
die schmecken schon so schon richtig gut.
Aber es werden ja Nougat-Plätzchen
und deswegen Doppeldecker.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach etwas Nougat
in der Flasche geschmolzen.
Ihr könnt das Ganze über dem Wasserbad machen.
Also ich habe es einfach so
mit der Teekanne gemacht.
Ich habe das so reingestellt
So rum reingestellt und dann gedreht,
dass der Nougat praktisch nach unten fließt.
Ihr könnt den Nougat in der Mikrowelle schmelzen.
Also, wie ihr wollt.
Mit einem Spritzbeutel auftragen,
mit einem Löffel, mit einem Messer,
wie ihr möchtet.
Und dann praktisch zwei Kekse übereinandersetzen
und fertig.
[Musik]
Ich nenne euch Joshs Favorite.
Kommen wir zu den zweiten Keksen
und zwar Schokoladenkekse.
Ich habe jetzt hier wieder meine Portion Teig.
Bei den Kakaokeksen, bei den Schokokeksen
könnt ihr es so machen,
dass ihr entweder direkt einen 1-2-3-Teig mit Kakao ansetzt,
also praktisch ein bisschen Mehl rauslassen,
dafür Kakao dazu,
oder ihr nehmt einfach den fertigen Teig,
knetet noch Kakao rein.
Es kann aber dann sein,
dass ihr vielleicht einen Esslöffel kaltes Wasser noch braucht.
Was ich dann zusätzlich noch dazu mache, ist Tonka Wonka,
das heißt Tonkabohne.
Entweder nehmt ihr die Tonkabohnen
und reibt so ein bisschen Abrieb rein,
ihr könnt aber auch Kaffee dazu geben, gemahlenen,
also wirklich wieder jeden Geschmack, den ihr möchtet,
oder Tonka Wonka direkt aus der Tube
praktisch fertig portioniert.
Zum Bestreichen nehme ich dann noch ein Eigelb
und dann hier noch die Schokostreusel.
Also den Teig hinein
und dann Kakaopulver dazu
und Tonka Wonka.
Und verkneten.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt meinen fertigen Teig.
Auch hier ist wieder wichtig:
Der Teig sollte jetzt schön kalt sein.
Ich werde ihn jetzt ausrollen.
Und da nehmt ihr wirklich immer ganz, ganz wenig Mehl.
Das ist so der Fehler, den die meisten machen.
Denn, wenn ihr jetzt zu viel Mehl dazu gebt
und immer wieder einknetet,
wird der Teig eben schnell trocken.
Tipp Nummer
keine Ahnung wie viel ist,
dass ihr die Plätzchen immer gleich dick ausrollen solltet.
Das heißt, entweder nehmt ihr so Abstandshölzer
oder ihr nehmt
Gegenstände wie zum Beispiel ganz flache Lego-Hölzchen,
irgendwas, wo ihr wirklich rechts und links davon legen könnt
und sagen könnt:
"Okay, der Plätzchenteig wird gleichmäßig ausgerollt",
damit eben auch die Backzeit gleich ist.
Dann sind die Plätzchen eben gleichmäßig braun,
gleichmäßig durch,
nichts verbrennt, nichts bleibt roh.
Entweder Abstandshölzer
oder ihr könnt auch den Ausrollstab nehmen
mit Abstandsringen.
Also da gibt es wirklich ganz viele
verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Ich mache jetzt die 5-mm-Ringe dran.
Ich habe aber auch schon
die Essstäbchen benutzt.
Also da könnt ihr euch wirklich mit vielem behelfen.
Und dann den Teig schön ausrollen.
Nur, wenn er doch mal unten festsitzt,
hier vorne Mehl drauf streuen
und mit einer Palette sozusagen das Mehl drunterziehen.
So könnt ihr wirklich mit ganz, ganz wenig Mehl arbeiten.
[Musik]
Und jetzt sucht ihr euch einfach Ausstecher eurer Wahl aus.
Ich nehme jetzt hier diesen runden Ausstecher
und werde gleich Kekse machen,
die in der Mitte aber ein Loch haben.
Dann kann man sie zum Beispiel auch mal aufhängen.
Oder allgemein finde ich es halt einfach echt süß.
Und hier ist jetzt wichtig,
dass ihr gleich große Kekse immer auf ein Blech packt,
eben auch wegen der Backzeit.
[Musik]
Und dann könnt ihr mit einer Spritztülle
oder mit einem Miniausstecher hier in der Mitte noch
die kleine Vertiefung ausstechen.
Und ich nehme diesen Minikeks und backe den auch.
Aber ihr könnt den auch einfach noch mal verkneten
und den übrigen Teig ausstechen.
Und da wirklich wichtig:
Wenn hier ein bisschen Mehl dran ist,
ein bisschen wegstäuben.
Zusammenkneten und, wenn der Teig zu weich wird,
einfach noch mal kurz kühlen.
[Musik]
Bevor ich diese Kekse jetzt allerdings bestreiche und backe,
werde ich sie noch mal kühlen im Gefrierschrank
für etwa 15 Minuten.
Und da verlieren sie dann beim Backen ihre Form nicht.
Also hier immer darauf achten:
Die Keksteige müssen wirklich superkalt sein.
[Musik]
Die Kekse sind jetzt schön gekühlt, wie ihr sehen könnt.
Okay, das kann man nicht sehen.
Aber ich weiß es.
Und jetzt bestreiche ich sie an der Oberfläche mit Eigelb.
So ein bisschen vorher verrühren.
[Musik]
Und dann könnt ihr entweder Schokostreusel
oder Schokoplättchen nehmen
und sie mit der Oberfläche eintauchen.
[Musik]
Die kommen jetzt in den Backofen
und sind dann auch schon fertig.
Warte. Dann mache ich die da oben rein
und die kleinen kommen gleich direkt mit drunter.
[Musik]
Ein Dieb!
Wir haben einen Dieb in der Küche!
Sag mal!
>> SARAH: Ta-daa!
>> SALLY: Das hast du gemeint, ob du was vom...
Ich habe gedacht, du willst einfach nur Deko klauen.
Dass du jetzt einen ganzen Ast hier mitnimmst,
habe ich halt nicht gewusst.
[Musik]
Zimtschneckenplätzchen,
das machen wir als Nächstes.
Das Rezept gibt es tatsächlich auf meinem Kanal.
Aber ich habe es jetzt hier
einfach noch mal optimiert und vereinfacht für euch.
Ich nehme praktisch den hellen Teig,
also den Keksteig, den ich vorbereitet habe,
und mache jetzt eine Zimtschneckenfüllung.
Die besteht aus Mandeln,
– da nehme ich jetzt diese mit Schale –
Eiweiß,
braunen Zucker und Zimt.
Und das Ganze wird jetzt einfach kurz püriert.
Ich mache das hier in der Gewürzmühle,
aber ihr könnt auch einfach einen Pürierstab nehmen
oder direkt einfach gemahlene Mandeln.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Oder einen anderen Mixer,
was ihr eben dahabt.
>> JOSH: Mit der Hand.
>> SALLY: Mit der Hand?
Äh, wie heißt der?
Chuck Norris.
>> JOSH: Ach so, der.
>> SALLY: Chuck Norris würde die Paste
natürlich mit der Hand machen.
[Musik]
So sieht die Füllung jetzt aus.
Mmh!
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euren Teig,
rollt den gleichmäßig dünn aus
und zwar als Rechteck.
Ich zeige euch auch gleich wie.
Am besten ungefähr 3 mm dick.
Und jetzt nutzt ihr sozusagen die Silikonmatte,
klappt es um,
einmal hier,
rollt hier drüber.
Denn dann bekommt ihr hier diese gerade Kante.
Genauso andersrum.
[Musik]
Es muss ja nur so ungefähr.
Nicht perfekt,
aber so bekommt ihr schon mal da noch eine Kante.
Und jetzt mache ich es praktisch noch einmal so
und dann habe ich ungefähr die Richtung.
So ein bisschen wie beim Nudelteigformen.
Also, wenn man Nudelteig ausrollt mit der Walze,
faltet man den ja auch immer wieder,
bis man eine schöne Platte hat,
und dann wird es eben in die richtige Richtung ausgerollt.
So. Und ich mache jetzt einfach den Rest so.
Das passt perfekt.
Dann kommt jetzt hier die Füllung drauf.
[Musik]
Dann schneide ich hier einmal durch.
Und, bevor ich es aber ausrolle
– aufrolle,
noch mal schauen, dass nichts anklebt.
Und dann schön aufrollen.
[Musik]
Und dann nehme ich hier diese Rolle,
packe es in mein Bienenwachstuch
zum Einfrieren, denn jetzt ist sie noch zu weich.
Hier könnt ihr auch so ein bisschen
noch schön eine Form geben,
indem ihr das so ein bisschen spannt.
[Musik]
Und dann schneidet ihr die geschnittenen Rollen
einfach in 1 cm breite Scheiben,
legt sie auf das Blech und könnt sie direkt backen.
[Musik]
Jetzt gibt es Zimtkarten.
Dafür nehme ich wieder den hellen Basisteig,
knete hier zwei Teelöffel Zimt ein.
[Musik]
Den Teig rolle ich jetzt 3 mm dünn aus.
Jetzt könnt ihr daraus Karten ausstechen
mit einem eckigen Ausstecher,
ihr könnt sie schneiden,
ihr könnt sie mit einem gewellten Pizzarädchen,
was stumpf ist natürlich wegen der Silikonmatte,
ausschneiden, ihr könnt einen Raviolischneider nehmen,
ihr könnt machen, was ihr möchtet.
Ihr könnt sie auch gerne vorher noch strukturieren.
Ich glaube,
ich – den hatte ich ja schon mal.
Ich glaube, ich nehme Rauten.
Ich probiere es mal kurz an einer Ecke aus.
Schon süß!
Oder große Rauten?
Auch schön.
Heieiei!
Ich nehme die, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja, die sind cool.
>> SALLY: Ja, die nehme ich.
Ja.
Jetzt nehme ich diese Keksstrukturstempel,
Fondant-/Keks-/Marzipan-/Was-auch-immer-Strukturstempel,
präge das so ein.
Ihr könnt aber auch mit einer Gabel zum Beispiel
ein Muster reinmachen
oder auch das Ganze ohne Muster lassen, ja?
Aber die sind schon schön.
[Musik]
Ich hätte auch Fliesenleger werden können, Maler, Tapezierer,
alles, wo man eben saubere Schnittkanten
schön verdecken muss.
Jetzt schneide ich schöne Karten zurecht.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Ich lege einfach so ein Lineal in die Mitte
so als Abstand.
Das ist jetzt keine Produktplatzierung.
Eine Produktplatzierung wäre es,
wenn ich meinen Meterstab hinlegen würde.
So.
Das wäre eine Produktplatzierung.
Das ist keine.
Denn es ist mein Schullineal.
Und wenn ihr es dann so diagonal drüberlegt,
könnt ihr nämlich schöne Rauten machen.
Oh, das finde ich schön!
Und dann werde ich die Kekse
mit meiner Palette direkt auf das Blech setzen,
noch mal kühlen, damit sie schön eiskalt sind,
und dann im Ofen backen.
Und nach dem Backen werden sie direkt
mit Zimtzucker bestreut.
Wow! Weißt du, was ich vergessen habe?
Ich wollte den Prägestempel
– den hier wollte ich vorher in Zimt tauchen
und dann eintauchen!
Puh! Vergessen.
Also, wenn ihr möchtet, für eine extra Zimtstruktur
taucht ihr praktisch diesen Ausstecher
oder diesen Prägestempel vorher in Zimt
und dann hier rein.
Weil dann habt ihr noch mal so diese braunen Streifen drin.
Ach Mensch! Voll vergessen.
Ich bin aber auch dusselig.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommen meine Lieblingsplätzchen.
Okay, das hört man vielleicht oft,
aber die gehören schon zu meinen Favoriten,
nämlich die Hildabrötchen
oder auch Spitzbuben genannt
oder auch
Klebeplätzchen
oder auch Terrassenplätzchen,
nämlich Plätzchen mit Marmeladenfüllung.
Da nehme ich jetzt den hellen Teig,
rolle den gleichmäßig dünn aus.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier die Kekse
– oder den Teig besser gesagt,
es sind noch keine Kekse –
den Teig auf 3 mm ausgerollt.
Und jetzt nehme ich Ausstecherlein
– ich mache Herzchen –
und zwar einen großen und einen kleinen,
praktisch, dass obendrauf der Deckel ein Loch bekommt.
Und das Loch ist bei mir halt auch ein Herzchen.
Jetzt steche ich erst mal die großen Herzchen aus.
Und hier wieder darauf achten,
dass der Teig schön kalt ist.
Das heißt, dann noch mal vor dem Backen einfrieren.
[Musik]
Und da ist jetzt wichtig, dass die Kekse mit Loch
und die Kekse ohne Loch
auf zwei verschiedenen Blechen liegen,
eben wegen der Backzeit.
Und wenn sie dann auf dem Blech liegen,
steche ich hier in der Mitte das Loch aus.
So müsst ihr es nämlich nicht mehr wegbewegen
und das Plätzchen wird nicht zerstört.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier ein Blecht mit Loch,
ein Blech ohne Loch
und die werden dann gleich gebacken.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier meine Marmelade aufgekocht.
Ich habe eine Himbeermarmelade ohne Stückchen,
also fein passiert.
Die füllt ihr in einen Spritzbeutel, Gefrierbeutel
oder in die Dosierflasche.
Ich könnt es natürlich auch mit dem Messer auftragen,
aber ich finde, das ist dann immer
mit so vielen kleinen Keksen
– oder mit einem Löffel – echt immer schwieriger.
Und ich koche die gerne immer ein bisschen auf,
damit auch so ein bisschen die Feuchtigkeit verdunstet
und die so ein bisschen fester wird.
So. Dann habe ich jetzt hier den Deckel.
Der wird mit süßem Schnee bestreut
im Vorfeld.
[Musik]
Und ein bisschen Glitzer!
Und dann am besten die Marmelade kurz prüfen,
auf einem Teller zum Beispiel, ob sie gut fließt.
Ich habe sie jetzt kurz abkühlen lassen.
Ich habe einfach kurz die Flasche verschlossen
unter kaltes Wasser.
Und jetzt ist sie nicht mehr ganz so flüssig und ich kann damit
die Unterseite sozusagen belegen.
[Musik]
Und dann den zweiten Keks obendraufsetzen.
Jetzt machen wir hier noch ein paar Ausstecherle-Kekse,
also ganz normale Plätzchen.
Da darfst du jetzt mal deine Formen raussuchen.
Und, guck mal, die sollten ungefähr gleich groß sein,
damit die auch eine gleiche Backzeit haben auf einem Blech.
Magst du hier noch den Stern?
Ja, passt, nicht?
Ich meine, du kannst auch noch einen kleinen machen später.
>> ELA: Warte. Nein, ich will das da,
die zwei...
>> SALLY: Das und vielleicht noch so eine Blume?
>> ELA: Ja. Und...
>> SALLY: Da bei dir.
>> ELA: Und einen...
>> SALLY: Und einen Tannenbaum, he?
Und hier noch so eine Blume.
>> ELA: Ja. Und einen
Buchstaben.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Aber ich zeige dir jetzt mal erst mal,
wie du wie ein Profi Teig ausrollen kannst,
okay?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also ich mache es hier
und du machst es hier, ja?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und wir arbeiten parallel,
wie Partner sozusagen.
Halt, warte.
Das ist deiner. Guck mal.
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Doch, doch. Ich zeige dir auch warum.
Denn, wenn ihr mit Kindern ausrollt
– ich habe jetzt hier nämlich schon die Abstandsringe dran.
Dann kann sie nämlich den Teig
gar nicht erst ungleichmäßig ausrollen.
Da habe ich jetzt die 5 mm dran. Das passt.
Nicht zu dünn.
Jetzt nehmen wir hier ganz wenig Mehl.
Und dann verteilst du es immer so mit der Hand, ja?
Okay?
Und gleich...
Und gleich nehmen wir einen Ventilator
und dann mache ich so
und wasche meine Hände so.
>> SALLY: Dann kriegst du hier den Teig.
Also schau mal, Ela.
Den Teig hinlegen
und ganz wenig Mehl in die Hand
und noch mal so drüberstreichen.
>> ELA: Okay.
So?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Genau.
>> ELA: Nein. Oder so.
So.
>> SALLY: Oh, warte mal.
Die Ärmelchen machen wir noch hoch.
So wie bei Mama, ja?
Zeig mal kurz dein Ärmelchen.
Sag mal. Kann das sein?
Bist du mein kleines Mini-Me?
Bist du die kleine Sally?
Nein. Du bist die große Ela, gell?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Genau. Und guck mal.
Jetzt guck mal, guck mal ganz kurz Mama zu.
Ein bisschen rollen und jetzt den Teig drehen.
Und wenn er sich nicht drehen lässt,
genau, kannst du das hier machen.
So.
Und dann wieder rollen.
>> ELA: Und dann die ganze Zeit rollen?
>> SALLY: Und dann die ganze Zeit rollen.
Ich mache mal...
>> ELA: Bis er dünn genug ist?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Ist er bei mir dünn genug?
>> SALLY: Noch nicht.
Guck mal. Warte.
Und noch mal.
So. Und jetzt drehen wir ihn mal so,
damit er auch in die Breite ausgerollt wird.
>> ELA: Ups!
>> SALLY: Wenn er klebt,
wieder ein bisschen Mehl auf die Oberfläche. So.
Ganz wenig aber immer. Ganz, ganz, ganz wenig.
Dann gehe ich noch mal so drunter.
>> ELA: Jetzt kommt so.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Einfach, dass er nicht anklebt.
Und ich tu die Ausstecher mal hier rüber.
Nicht!
Oh!
Wow, ein Flip-over!
Zeig mal. Jetzt passt es perfekt!
Jetzt ist er super.
Guck mal. Jetzt nimmst du deine Ausstecher.
>> ELA: Ist es das?
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist super.
Und dann direkt den nächsten hier so dransetzen,
damit du so viele Plätzchen wie möglich
aus einem Teig ausstechen kannst.
Und die legst du dann
direkt hier drauf.
Stich am besten erst aus und dann nehmen wir sie runter.
Aus dem gleichen Teig mache ich jetzt auch Bonbonkekse.
Dafür rollt ihr den Teig jetzt 5 mm dick aus
und dann auch ein Fenster in die Mitte
[Musik]
Das Internet ist gelöscht.
Ela, das Internet ist gelöscht!
Es gibt nie wieder Netflix, YouTube, My Little Pony.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Was sollen wir jetzt tun?
Das Internet ist gelöscht!
Wir können jetzt auch keine Videos mehr hochladen.
Was machen wir jetzt?
>> ELA: Das ist nicht gelöscht.
>> SALLY: Doch! Die können oben nicht arbeiten gerade.
Die von der Baustelle, der Bagger hat das Internet zerstört.
Jetzt gibt es kein Internet mehr auf der Welt.
Was machen wir jetzt?
>> ELA: Was hat der gemacht?
>> SALLY: Der hat das Kabel zerstört.
Okay.
>> ELA: Welches?
>> SALLY: Warte mal. Also
sollen wir dann einfach eine Bäckerei gründen
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SALLY: und jeden Tag backen und Kekse verkaufen?
>> ELA: Nein. Ich habe eine Idee.
>> SALLY: Ja, sag mal.
>> ELA: Wir müssen einen Internetsteller holen,
damit der wieder das Internet reparieren kann.
>> SALLY: Aber wenn das nicht mehr geht?
>> ELA: Oh!
Darüber habe ich nicht nachgedacht.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich ja auch nicht.
Mh.
>> ELA: Dann müssen wir es halt so verbinden wieder.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber was wäre eine Welt ohne Internet?
Das wäre doch okay, oder?
>> ELA: Wir reparieren
>> SALLY: Das wäre doch auch okay.
>> ELA: das Kabel.
>> SALLY: Keine Videos mehr.
Dann müssten wir halt wieder andere Dinge tun.
>> ELA: Warte. Der Bagger?
Können wir es nicht...
Der Bagger...
Wie hat der das angestellt?
>> SALLY: Das frage ich mich auch.
>> ELA: Aber, wenn Internet geht, dann gibt es nicht
keinen Strom.
Aber...
Aber Strom gibt es ja gerade.
>> SALLY: Ja, Strom gibt es, aber kein Internet mehr.
>> ELA: Ich gucke kurz,
ob ihr mich veräppelt.
>> SALLY: Es ist halt echt so.
Wir hatten gerade den Megastromausfall.
Alles war weg, Internet weg,
oben alle arbeitslos plötzlich.
Aber die Ela, die kriegt man nicht veräppelt, gell?
[Musik]
>> ELA: Das funktioniert nicht bei allen oben.
>> SALLY: Was denn, Schatz? Komm mal her.
>> ELA: Das Internet.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> ELA: Sie will gerade...
Aylin hat es gezeigt mir.
Hä?!
Ich hatte das doch größer ausgerollt!
>> SALLY: Nö.
Ich habe dir nichts weggenascht.
Diese Blumenrahmen kommen jetzt bei mir
wieder in den Gefrierschrank, damit sie schön fest werden.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
werde ich schon mal Bonbons zerkleinern,
nämlich ganz normale Bonbons in jeglicher Farbe.
Transparent sollten sie sein.
Und die werden hier dann reingefüllt und mitgebacken.
Und dann habe ich nämlich
Plätzchen mit einem Bonbonfenster.
[Musik]
Für die Bonbonplätzchen
habe ich eine reizende Assistentin,
die hier diese Bonbons kurz zerkleinern wird.
Nimm ruhig alle.
[Musik]
Also das waren jetzt Bonbons mit Füllung.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen blöd.
Das wusste ich jetzt auch vorher nicht.
Waren nimm2 schon immer mit Füllung?
Ah, stimmt! In der Mitte.
Und wir haben keine ohne, nicht?
Egal.
Wir probieren es jetzt trotzdem.
Das kommt jetzt hier rein
und dann kommen die in den Backofen.
Und da zerläuft das nämlich.
Und nach dem Backen müssen sie aber
auf jeden Fall gut abkühlen,
bevor ihr sie dann hochnehmt.
>> SAMIRA: Ups.
>> SALLY: Das Ganze kann man übrigens
auch einfach mit Isomalt machen.
Also, wenn ihr Isomalt daheim habt,
mit ein bisschen Lebensmittelfarbe einfärben
oder durchsichtig lassen.
>> SAMIRA: Und noch unsere Zuckerpaste rein.
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was mein Favorite wäre?
Eisbonbons.
So Elsakekse.
Ich glaube, da machen wir mal so Eisprinzessinkekse.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Möchtest du vielleicht Herzchen machen?
Wir haben noch gar keine Herzchen.
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und guck, immer so schön nebeneinander,
damit wir...
Nicht mittenrein.
Schön am Rand anfangen. Ja.
Ja!
>> ELA: Aber halt, das war noch nicht alles!
>> SALLY: Na klar.
Habe ich auch von dir gar nicht anders erwartet.
Guck mal. Wenn du die ausstichst,
dann halte den Ausstecher hier so oben
und drück hier oben fest.
Ja?
>> ELA: Und warum nicht so?
>> SALLY: Immer mit der spitzen Seite.
>> ELA: Mami, wo ist mein schönes Herz?
Das war doch noch nicht fertig.
>> SALLY: Das sieht jetzt aus wie ein Seestern, gell?
>> ELA: Ja. Ich muss kurz noch was machen.
Mama?
>> SALLY: Ja?
Was?
>> ELA: Ich brauche einen Seestern.
>> SALLY: Einen was?!
>> ELA: Einen Seestern.
>> SALLY: Ich habe keinen Seestern.
Okay, das ist gelogen.
>> ELA: Nein! Ich meinte damit Punkte,
solche Punktlöcher.
>> SALLY: Aha! Das kannst du gleich mit Streuseln machen.
>> ELA: Nein. Wir machen so mal Punkte.
Dann sieht es richtig aus wie ein Seestern.
>> SALLY: Wow! Ich fühle mich neben Ela richtig dumm.
Jede Idee, die ich ihr vorschlage,
schlägt sie mir einfach aus.
Ich komme mir richtig blöd vor.
Nein, nicht mit dem Stift!
Oh!
Hey, ist aber eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Aber nein, das macht man nicht mit dem Stift.
Denn den Stift kann man ja nicht essen.
>> ELA: Bäh!
>> SALLY: Wir können einen Strohhalm oder so nehmen,
was Kleines.
>> ELA: Ja, einen Strohhalm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Einfach, wenn ich da einen Regenbogen...
>> SALLY: So. Und bevor wir die backen,
werden die noch eingefroren,
damit sie beim Backen die Form behalten.
Und entweder kann man sie vor dem Backen
mit Eigelb bestreichen und mit Zuckerstreuseln bestreuen
– dann backen die so ein bisschen mit –
oder man kann sie pur backen
und sozusagen nach dem Backen
mit einer Zitronen-Puderzucker-Glasur bestreichen
und dann bestreuen.
Könnt ihr dann entscheiden.
Das sind so meine Kindergartenplätzchen.
Also die habe ich als Kind im Kindergarten schon gebacken.
Und ich glaube, dass auch die Erzieherinnen
mit uns das so gemacht haben,
praktisch mit Eigelb bestreichen,
Zuckerstreusel drauf und dann in den Ofen.
Dann ist man fertig.
Denn es ist ja schon so,
– so habe ich es auch in der Schule
praktisch mit meinen Schülern erlebt –
dass Kinder eben auch mal gern
die Finger in den Mund nehmen und was abschlecken.
Und dann ist es halt schon unhygienisch,
wenn du praktisch nach dem Keksbacken
das Ganze mit Zitronen-Puderzucker-Glasur machst
und dann noch mal mit Streuseln.
Weil die werden ja dann nicht mehr gebacken.
Wenn es vorher passiert
und das Ganze dann bei 190°C in den Backofen kommt,
bleibt da halt nichts mehr übrig.
Deswegen ist das so die perfekte Keksvariante mit Deko,
die man mit Kindern machen kann,
auch mit fremden Kindern,
oder einfach, wo man echt sichergehen kann,
dass da nichts passiert.
Und es sind meine Kindergartenkekse!
Oh, da freue ich mich aufs Essen!
[Musik]
Die anderen Ausstecherle hier, die wollen wir jetzt
mit der Zitronen-Puderzucker-Glasur machen.
Und da habe ich jetzt einfach
Puderzucker und Zitrone verrührt,
ein bisschen Vanille noch rein.
Und hier habe ich jetzt Lebensmittelfarbpasten
und werde die noch pastellfarben einfärben.
Und dann können wir die schön dekorieren, okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
[Musik]
Was ich jetzt hier noch machen werde:
Die Hildabrötchen, die habe ich ja
mit dem Vanilleteig gemacht.
Ich mache aber noch Hildabrötchen mit Lemon Curd.
Mein Lemon Curd, das gibt es bereits auf meinem Kanal.
Das ist einfach eine richtig leckere Zitronencreme,
die ich später auch da reinfüllen werde.
Und dafür nehme ich dann noch eine Zitrone,
gebe den Abrieb mit zum Teig,
steche dann auch die Kekse aus
so wie bei den Hildabrötchen.
Was ihr auch nehmen könnt stattdessen,
wäre so eine Zitronenpaste.
Da ist bereits der Zitronenabrieb drin.
Und dann hat der Keks
praktisch schon den Zitronengeschmack
und dann habe ich später noch die Zitronenfüllung.
Halt! Du kannst nicht den Teig reiben.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Da ist der Güni.
>> ELA: Der hat mir zuerst die Zunge rausgestreckt.
>> SALLY: Hier, du kriegst auch ein bisschen Zitrone.
[Musik]
Mir ist was eingefallen!
Guckt mal. Ich mache jetzt hier noch die mit Lemon Curd
und da nehme ich einfach Spritztüllen
mit verschiedenen Lochtüllengrößen
und steche jetzt hier praktisch das Plätzchen,
was obendrauf kommt, damit aus.
Und dann kam mir die Idee:
"O mein Gott! Ich muss mal mit Ela oder Samira oder beiden
so kleine Tiertatzen machen."
Weißt du? So in der Mitte und dann die Füße außenrum
und dann mit Nougat füllen oder Schnee oder...
Ach Gott!
Ach, ich...
Ich sage es euch, diese Plätzchenreihe, die...
Es gibt kein Ende.
Es tut mir echt leid.
[Musik]
Das Lemon Curd habe ich jetzt auch leicht erwärmt
und hier wieder in die Dosierflasche gefüllt.
Und jetzt kann ich hier
die Unterseite der Kekse damit befüllen.
[Musik]
Okay, jetzt habt ihr erkannt,
mittlerweile ist schon der nächste Tag.
Ich habe jetzt hier diese Lemon Cookies fertig,
die Zitronen-Cookies,
und werde die jetzt aber noch
mit Kuvertüre verschönern, dekorieren.
Ich habe jetzt hier so einen Minispritzbeutel.
Da kann ich nämlich direkt weiße Kuvertüre-Chips
beziehungsweise weiße Kuvertüre, gehackte Kuvertüre
einfach schmelzen
und dann so in Streifen drüberlaufen lassen.
[Musik]
Also hier haben wir jetzt unsere Plätzchen.
Komm, Sarah. Du darfst auch probieren.
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Es sind echt viele geworden,
muss ich dazu sagen.
Also mein Favorit sind eigentlich immer
hier die Hildabrötchen.
Aber ich glaube, auch Lemon Curd wäre auch.
Und ich habe vorhin von deinem Anbiss
den Nougat-
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, wow!
Der Nougat-Keks, der ist schon...
Was hast du ausgesucht?
Natürlich die mit Zuckerguss.
>> SARAH: Die farbigen, gell?
>> SALLY: Habt ihr die auch gesehen?
>> SARAH: Aber warum nicht Pink?
>> SALLY: Das sind auch die mit dem Bonbon in der Mitte.
>> SAMIRA: Da haben wir dir mitgeholfen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Welchen nehme ich?
>> SALLY: Was nehme ich?
>> SARAH: Der war beim Anbiss auch...
>> SAMIRA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: War auch lecker, nicht?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> SAMIRA: Nimm so einen.
>> SALLY: So einen?
Darf ich bei dir so ein Stück?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich will auch keinen ganzen.
>> SALLY: Zeig mal.
Teilen wir uns einen?
>> ELA: Ich habe den Frozen-Keks.
>> SARAH: Sollen wir uns den Lemon Curd teilen?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Ich habe den Frozen-Keks.
>> SARAH: Der bricht.
>> SALLY: Also man muss echt sagen,
die schmecken am nächsten Tag immer besser,
so, wenn sie eine Nacht durchgezogen sind.
>> SARAH: Wow!
>> SALLY: Und Plätzchen allgemein am besten immer
einzeln verpackt, also jede Sorte für sich verpackt
aufbewahren, damit sich die Aromen nicht vermischen.
Und dann
– ja, der muss noch ein bisschen.
>> SARAH: Ich nehme das mit der weißen Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und dann
>> SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: sind die nämlich megalecker
und mehrere Wochen haltbar.
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Jetzt dürft ihr gerne eure
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Rezepte oder die Rezepte nachmachen
und ausprobieren,
mir gerne euer Feedback geben.
>> ELA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und, wie gesagt, das geht superschnell.
Also einmal diesen großen Teig zubereitet
könnt ihr auf einmal diese Plätzchenbäckerei machen
und ganz viele Kekse auf einmal zaubern.
Bis bald und viel Spaß!
>> SARAH: Welcher gefällt dir am besten?
>> SALLY: Hat es euch den Spaß gemacht?
>> SAMIRA: Ja. Ich zähle gerade aus,
welchen ich essen soll noch.
>> SALLY: Ach so.
Ela, hat es dir Spaß gemacht, das Plätzchenbacken?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Mir auch.
>> SARAH: Mir auch.
>> SALLY: Du Arme! Du musstest sie alle fotografieren.
>> SARAH: Und alle probieren.
>> SALLY: Und alle probieren. Ojemine!
Tschüss!
>> ELA: Ihr habt die gar nicht fotografiert.
>> SARAH: Die sind schon fotografiert.
>> SAMIRA: Und ich helfe beim Essen.
>> SARAH: Sonst könntest du sie jetzt gerade nicht essen.
>> SALLY: Ela, kennst du das Lied
"In der Weihnachtsbäckerei"?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: So war es bei uns, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ah, da macht jemand die Rollos runter.
>> SARAH: Sie fängt an zu klatschen.
>> SALLY: Da macht einfach jemand die Rollos runter.
Machen wir halt Feierabend.
Okay.
Tschüss!
[Musik]